I have a really interesting clip for you from
MSNBC where a conservative mother and daughter
and then some third.
Yeah,
the guy, I'm not sure the relationship of
the third guy you'll see standing in the background,
uh, to the mother and daughter are interviewed
in Iowa.
These are Iowa, presumably Iowa voters in
2020 and they're interviewed by MSNBC.
And first the mother explains that she simply
can't bring herself to vote for Donald Trump
in 2020.
Take a look
yourself politically and why you went with
Carla Harris.
And what do you want?
Well, I'm a lifelong conservative, but I actually
campaigned door to door for Chuck Grassley
his first year as a senate campaign, Senate
candidate.
Um, but I cannot vote for Donald Trump.
I just, he is, he is not a conservative and
I don't think he's a good man.
And when you watch, um, at cabinet member
after cabinet member fall away from him, I
just can't vote for him.
And so I'm looking at the Democrats and I
need a Democrat that is um, reasonable on
our borders that is about people.
It's about the rule of law.
I'm an educator and we've got to do something
about education.
And so that's the person that I'm looking
for and it's really hard because there are
all these dumb sculptures and they really
don't know what they believe.
And so that's what I'm looking for here.
Think you ended up voting, writing and John
McCain in 2016.
Paul, who did you vote for?
Frankly, from the way that this woman talks,
I don't think there's any place for her in
the Republican Party other than maybe if she's
anti-abortion, maybe that's really important
to her.
She doesn't sound like no 2019 Republican
I ever heard, but then it gets more interesting.
They go to the guy in the back and he says
he was voting against Hillary in 2016 not
for Trump.
He almost seems embarrassed to admit that
he voted for Donald Trump, but then he repeats
a totally incorrect talking point that is
spreading and that we really need to stop
like asap.
So take a listen to this.
Who did you vote for in the general election?
General election didn't vote for anybody.
I voted against Democrats.
So you put in for Donald Trump, I do this
time around.
Could you see yourself voting for a Democrat
right now or it's hard to say at this point
in the campaign up.
Buddy's running to the extremes on either
side.
So the defense we'll probably shoot for no
Marco.
They're all running to the extremes.
He says, no, that's not true.
This is, this is just a fundamental misunderstanding.
Either out of ignorance or out of malice or
something else.
Trump is doing the same thing he's been been
doing, which is to be an extremist in policy
and to be an extremist in rhetoric.
That's no different.
Trump is Trump and he's doing the same thing
he did as a candidate early in his presidency
and now Democrats are half centrists sort
of running to the center, left and half running
on the normal things that every other rich
country has.
No one on the left is running two extremes.
Biden, Harris and Buddha judge are running
basically on make no substantive changes to
the status quo.
The rich people don't need to worry, as Biden
said, behind closed doors.
Everything is going to be okay.
That is not extreme.
Then you have from the front runners who are
more on the left, Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren who are running on healthcare for all
dealing with income inequality a little bit
more than we've been dealing with it, dealing
with corporate power to some degree, the basics
that other Nordic countries, social democracies
and rich countries have already figured out.
So this is a false narrative and the both
sides ism that needs to be stopped includes
this story.
Well, listen, everybody's running to extreme,
so I don't know who I'm going to support.
No.
Uh, the left primary, the Democratic primary
better said right now is a combination of
centrist Democrats that will be very similar
to centrus Republicans and a couple of people
that are running on completely uncontroversial
social democratic policy that most other countries
at our level of development and income have
already figured out.
Right wingers are creating for themselves.
This narrative that it's all so extreme, it's
just not, it's not extreme on the democratic
side.
Then they go from this dude to the daughter,
take a listen to what she had to say.
Hey there, I want to bring you in real fast.
This is going to be your 17, but you're going
to be able to vote in November of 2020 you
said you consider yourself conservative too,
and your family.
Yeah, but how do you see yourself voting?
I can't vote for Donald Trump and if there
was a better conservative, I would probably
vote for them.
But he says so many things that are just absolutely
fascinating and even a couple, a little tweeting
foreign policy is not presidential enough.
So I really want a Democratic candidate that
I can get behind and support and like my mom
said, isn't completely crazy on immigration
and really who will make things like schools
safer so that I can have a place here in my
future and just make the country better.
In general, is there a candidate that catches
your mind?
Oh, I'm [inaudible] Harris right now, like
my mom.
But, uh, if any of them change their policies
so far, I know that a lot of my friends like
Warren and Sanders, but they're a little too
far for me.
So again, Warren and Sanders are too far left.
They're not.
They're totally standard social democrats
in any Nordic country in most European countries.
And also, I find it a little bit odd that
immigration is so big an issue for people
in Iowa, right?
I mean, once again, it's talking point politics,
immigration, what Trump talks about a ton.
We're going to have a report later on about
the number of lies that Donald Trump has been
telling and a plurality of those lies are
about immigration.
It's big in the media narrative, so Iowans
who are disgusted by Trump are talking about
immigration.
What about the tariffs that are destroying
Iowa farmers?
It seems like a much more relevant and present
and nearby issue for Iowans than immigration.
To have these three people that were interviewed
are somewhat more thoughtful than your average
Trump is, but they're still very skewed in
their views.
But my takeaway is this is still good, right?
These are good examples and good anecdotes
of some Republicans that are saying, you know,
I can't bring myself to vote for Donald Trump,
but there's no strategy for Democrats around
people like this.
What I mean by that is there are people that
are going to bail on Trump because of Trump's
actions.
To the extent that we continue to report on
what Donald Trump is doing, some of these
folks are going to vote for someone other
than Donald Trump.
We can't really waste time trying to convince,
convince them or convert them.
Though, as I've said before, it's not a strategy
to debate Trumpists and get them to change.
Change their minds.
Some of them will like these folks, but what
our strategy needs to be is get out the vote.
Find people already on our side who wouldn't
otherwise vote half the country doesn't vote.
Combine them with these sprinkling of Trumpists
like these two or three who are bailing on
Donald Trump, and maybe that'll help the eventual
democratic nominee pick up a state or two
in the Midwest or a state that Donald Trump
won in 2016 and the depressing realization
and the guy there said it, lots of people
are just voting against Democrats.
That's really hard to work with.
It's very hard to convert that into support
for the Democratic nominee.
No matter what arguments you make.
So we need to turn out our base.
There are millions and millions of people
who already agree with us.
They just don't vote.
They either don't care enough to vote or they
are too busy to vote or they don't understand
the importance of voting.
And that's who we need to be reaching out
to.